لذلك ، لا تحتاج الشركات المصرفية في
العديد من الصناعات فقط إلى المزيد من الأيام
في المكتب ، هل تشعر أن
انهيار svb سيتم تأجيله
كنوع من الحكاية التحذيرية لإعادة
العمال إلى المكتب وإلى
وجهة نظرك هل أنت قلق  حول التأثير
الذي سيحدث على العمال ،
وخاصة النساء ، بالنسبة لمن كان خيار
العمل من المنزل قد
غيّر حياتهم
بشكل جيد ، أعتقد أن العديد من الشركات تنظر
إلى هذا على أنه فرصة إذا كانت الشركات
ستقوم بسحب الأشخاص
إلى المكتب و  عدم توفير
المرونة وعدم توفير
التقدم الوظيفي الذي
تبحث عنه المجموعات الممثلة تمثيلا ناقصًا ، إنها فرصة
للشركات الأخرى للدخول والقول حسنًا
ثقافة العمل لعام 2019 ، فلنتركها
في عام 2019 ما هي الشركة التقدمية الحديثة
التي تعرفها والتي تمضي قدمًا.
2023 24-25 وإحضار
المجموعات الممثلة تمثيلا ناقصًا بشكل خاص
لأنه بالمناسبة ، لا تترك النساء قوة
العمل لأنهن لا يرغبن في
العمل بعد الآن أو لأنهن يفتقرن إلى
الطموح ، فإنهن يتركن القوى العاملة
لأنهن لا يحصلن على تلك
الفرص للتقدم  بينما ننتقل
إلى عالم القوى العاملة ، فإن جميع
المشكلات تعود إلى كل التحيز اللاواعي ، فهم
يبحثون عن مزيد من
المرونة حتى تنظر الشركات الذكية
إلى هذا ، وترى فرصة وتستفيد